hey Bushido meine Frage lautet was für
eine Musik hörst du eigentlich wenn du
World of Warcraft zockst und was ist
deine
Lieblingsklasse Musik beim war bei
Warcraft ist so eine Sache also da also
ich spiele selten wirklich einfach so
für mich alleine irgendwie also ich ich
farme vielleicht nachts ein bisschen
Gold oder Kräuter oder oder Ärze oder
sonst irgendwas und da höre ich dann
halt einfach irgendwie so Rap für mich
persönlich wenn ich aber Raid sozusagen
mit der G zusammen dann hö ich gar keine
Musik weil ich ziemlich viel Verkehr auf
dem Teamspeak habe ja und ziemlich viele
Leute da auch reden also nicht viele
Leute aber Leute sagen da wichtige
Sachen und wenn ich den nebenbei Musik
laufen habe und so dann habe ich das
irgendwie nicht gehört oder ich habe
links nicht gehört oder rechts nicht
gehört und dann stehe ich in der Mitte
obwohl alle auf der anderen Seite stehen
und ich habe es nicht gehört weil M&M zu
laut gerappt hat also beim raiden hö ich
gar keine Musik ich konzentriere mich
auf die die spielgeräusche und und und
ansonsten wie gesagt hö ich halt Rap
ansonsten
meine
Lieblingsklasse kann ich sogar nicht
sagen ich habe insgesamt fünf
verschiedene die Spiele und bin immer
mal am überlegen ob ich in irgendeiner
Pause halt mir irgendwie noch ein
sechsten oder siebten hochziehe aber im
Endeffekt ist so mein mein meine letzte
Entscheidung beim Krieger und beim
Druiden hängen geblieben und ich switche
immer so zwischen Druide Krieger also
das sind so die Sachen die mir am besten
gefallen und wie gesagt also ansonsten
wenn du spielen kannst kannst du jede
Klasse spielen